- Welcome now, officially, I'm Paul North.
I teach critical theory at Yale.
I'm happy to present today's
speaker in the series
that I'm hosting together
with my colleague at Ohio
State University, Paul Reitter.
The series is called "The
Value of Marx's Capital".
And these are the Franke lectures,
at the humanities, at the
Whitney Humanity Center at Yale.
I need to thank the Franke family
who make possible the Franke lectures.
That's Richard and Barbara Franke,
and these lectures are intended
to present important
topics in the humanities
to a wide and general audience.
I need to thank as I
always do Alice Kaplan
for making this possible
who stepped in to direct
the Whitney Humanity Center,
right when the pandemic hit.
And so there's a lot of plans,
and lots of interesting
things are gonna happen
as time moves on.
I need to thank Sandra Malan-Bowles
and Leana Hirschfeld Kroen
for doing the organizational side,
and Audrey Leak who's
the technical genius,
and a brilliant undergraduate at Yale.
Thank you very much, Audrey,
for running the show.
Okay, this is the way it's gonna
work as it has in the past.
We'll have the presentation
from our speaker,
and then we'll take questions.
I want to give room
for the students in the seminar
that I'm running on Marx's
"Capital, Volume One"
time to ask questions, but
I think we'll ask everyone
to put their questions in the chat
after the presentation is over.
So we don't lose track
of them, hang on to them,
write them down,
and I will open up the
floor when things end.
I'm really excited
to welcome our guest in
this way of welcoming
where we're just having
faces hanging on screens.
But I have been reading
a quote from a text,
from our speakers as they come in.
So I'm gonna start
with a quote from our
speaker from an early book,
and an important book
among many important books.
Here's the quote.
This is my translation,
"Marx does not intend a moral
criticism of capitalism.
It is not a question of justice
or the violation of certain norms,
but rather of the confirmation
of a state of affairs.
That capitalist production damages
elementary vital interests of workers.
In order to establish this, no," quote,
"right to an undamaged life," unquote,
"needs to be postulated
or anything like it.
Marx wants to show
scientifically, wissenschaftlich,
that this violation of vital interests
is inextricably bound up
with the capitalist system.
And in so far as insight
into this characteristic
of the capitalist system grows
for the working class it will
also lead to political action.
Not in the name of universal justice,
but in its own interest,
at least that is the
optimistic hope of Marx."
This is a quote from a book
that was originally published in 1991
by Michael Heinrich, our guest today
the book is "Die Wissenschaft vom Wert"
which is going into a, one
of the multiple additions that
his books tend to go through.
Michael Heinrich is a former collaborator
of the Marx-Engels-Gesamtausgabe
and was until 2016 professor of economics
at the HTW in Berlin.
His accomplishments
on paper are many and his books are by now
some of them in double digits of editions
I hate to look at a long career writing
in German only from the
English language perspective
but to make this short
for those listening, you can
read several titles in English.
First of all
"An Introduction to the Three
Volumes of Marx's Capital"
the most reasonable, the most introductory
and undistorted view, I
would say of the volumes
as they need to go together.
We can read in English the first volume
of what I think is a projected
three volume biography of Marx.
Is that right?
- [Michael] Four volumes.
- Four volumes, sorry.
And that is published in
English, the first volume
"Karl Marx and the Birth
of the Modern Society"
from 2019, a further commentary,
how to read Marx's "Capital"
which is an extensive
commentary on the beginning
chapters is in the works
in English will come out
from Monthly Review Press.
And again, for those of
you who can read German,
I wanna point you
to this important leap in
the ballet of the debate
over the theory of value,
"Die Wissenschaft vom Wert"
from 1991, a really valuable
and important contribution.
Thank you for coming Michael.
Welcome, and I'll give
the floor over to you.
- Yes, thank you very much
for invitation to speak here.
And also thank you very
much for the introduction.
I just have to
add one point to the way you introduced me
the book you mentioned
"Wissenschaft vom Wert"
will also appear in
English finally next year.
And it is my thickest book.
The first edition from 91 was
considerably extended in 99.
And of course the extended
version will appear in English.
So now, also I have to
excuse my poor English.
When I hear myself later I
see how many mistakes I make
but I hope at least the
sense of the sentences
will become clear.
Also the English is a
little bit poor sometimes.
I was invited here to talk
about Marx value theory
and the original title
of my talk was "Marx
Monetary Value Theory".
I changed a little bit the
title, perhaps you saw it
when I sent the table of contents,
I added reading, "Reading
Marx Monetary Value Theory".
I did this because at first
we really have to talk
about, in which way do we talk
about Marx value theory, very usual
and widespread is a way
of talking that maybe I
present my interpretation.
It is opposed to some
alternative interpretations.
I support my interpretation
with some quotes from Marx.
My opponent supports his
or her interpretation
with some other quotes.
And when I found five quotes
in five of my interpretation
and the opponent found only three quotes
then it looks like that I am the winner
of the game, like in a soccer game.
But this is of course nonsense
to treat the things like this.
Of course, we have to
read cautiously, the texts
but we cannot reduce reading
of finding appropriate quotations.
And in so far, I will start
with the prerequisites of
discussing Marx value theory.
I think there are two prerequisites.
The first is a kind of
double historiography.
And the other is
that we really need a
critical reading instead
of looking for a last version,
what these points mean,
I will explain first
and then I will come
to the critical issues
of Marx value theory and the consequences
of these issues for the
understanding of capitalism.
So what I do, I mean this
double historiography
by the way, I used historiography
as translation for the German,
(speaks in foreign language).
I hope it fits more or less.
I think the must put in
a historiography as well
our own point of view
as well Marx situation
and his writing about his issues.
So what means historiography
of our own talking
about Marx value theory?
When we talk about Marx
our views are not only
influenced by our own positions.
They are also influenced
by our historical situation
in a very wide understanding, for example
talking about Marx before
the Russian revolution
and after was a big difference.
Before the collapse
of the Soviet union and
after is a big difference.
So historical events play a role
but also theoretical events play a role.
Already in the social democracy
in the very late 19th century
started a talk about
dialectical materialism
as philosophical basis,
historical materialism
as the approach to history of Marxism.
But we have to have in mind
that all these terms didn't
appear in Marx writings
he never used the term
dialectical materialism.
He never used the term
historical materialism
and about Marxism,
he did this famous phrase,
"I am not a Marxist".
And it was not a phrase only it expressed
a distrust against ism.
So Marx not at all wanted
to be the founder of an ism
but nevertheless, such
categories are taken mostly
for granted when we talk about Marx.
And I cannot go deeper in this discussion.
I just want to say behave very
cautious in using such categories.
When we now come to discussing value
theory and additional historical
difficulty emerges just a few years
after Marx published "Capital volume One"
in the year 1867,
the so-called marginal
revolution started in economics.
Carl Menger in Austria,
Leon Walras in Switzerland
and William Stanley Jevons in England
published independently studies
promoting the so-called
marginal utility theory.
It was a new approach to bring
utility into economic thinking.
Adam Smiths denied that utility
can explain value the marginalists
with these marginal utility
renewed the approach.
And it lasted only 20 years
that this new approach became dominant
and this had enormous
consequences for the perception
and also for the discussion
of Marx value theory.
The tradition of the marginalists
they created a new view on
the possible value theories.
On the one hand, it was said
we have the so-called objective theories
of value resting on
labor, production costs.
On the other hand, we have the
subjective theories of value.
They are built on consumer
preferences and utility.
In this distinction, Marx
and the classical political economists
like Adam Smith and David Ricardo are
in one camp the differences
between them are minimized
for many readers, no matter
if Marxists or critics of
Marx, the original claim
of Marx to deliver a fundamental critique
of a classical political
economy disappeared.
So it was only the question labor theory
when we talk about value, do
we have a labor theory of value
or do we have a utility theory of value?
But I think this way
of framing value theory
is totally misleading.
Not only at Marx, already with Smiths.
Smiths justified labor
as a matter of value by
the subjective evaluation
of the producer, where he said,
"Yes, labor is the real cost
because it provokes misery to the producer
and he will not have an
exchange of a labor product
with something else which
he can get for less labor".
So Adam Smiths in a subjective way
gave reason to the so-called
objective approach to value theory.
So I think all these
distinctions, objective subjective
labor theories, utility
theories have only a very,
very limited use, but nevertheless
they are used in a way as if
we can take them for granted.
Last point I want to
mention what is important
for our present perception
of Marx or of, not of
Marx theory in general,
but of "Capital".
"Capital" as we know, three volumes.
Unfortunately, most people
read only volume one,
but the three volumes of capital
form a unit, very important categories
like profit and interest
appear only in volume three.
When you don't know what
Marx means with profit
you will automatically tend to confuse
surplus value, category
of volume one, with profit
and entrepreneurial gain,
categories of volume three.
So we really need all
three volumes to read.
But when we look to history volume one
appeared in the year 1867.
Volume three after Marx
death edited by his friend
Frederick Engels appeared
nearly 30 years later in 1894.
And while volume one was nicely finished
by Marx was nicely presented by Marx,
volume two and three
Engels had to construct out
of unfinished manuscripts and to
read it is much more difficult
than to read volume one.
As a result, since 100
years, we have the situation
that volume one dominates
the reception of "Capital".
Volume one deals with
the production process of
capital and many Marxists
as well as Marx critics belief
here we find the real core
of Marx analysis of
capitalism and what is said
in volume two or three are some
details, additional details.
We must not go too much in
depth occupying with them.
And I think this is a
very wrong interpretation
a very wrong accentuation of capital.
So these were some very brief remarks
about the historiography
of our own position
that we have to be cautious
to take things for granted
which are the result of a
certain historical process.
We just shouldn't trust what is offered
as a categories, things
we can take for granted.
Now I come
to my second point, the historiography
of Marx analysis of value.
In general, we have to put Marx
theoretical texts, much more
in the conflict of his times
than this is usually done.
Most readers of "Capital",
they want to learn something
about contemporary capitalism.
It is said,
"Yes, Marx is an important author.
He has something to say,
read it," and they read it.
But most readers are
not clear about the fact
that all Marx texts also
"Capital" is an intervention
in debates, in conflicts,
in struggles of his times.
It is not a timeless
analytical effort to contribute
to the wisdom of human mankind.
And so we have to reconstruct all
these contemporary, for Marx,
contemporary struggles and debates
in order to get a deeper
understanding of the writings.
And you mentioned my Marx biography.
This is one of the main
tasks of this biography.
It is not to tell you
every detail of Marx life
and what was his dinner
on Sunday evening or something like that.
No, I think we need the biography
for really have the context
of his writings, to
understand the conflicts
to understand also Marx
standing in these conflicts
which was changing, Marx
was all his lifetime
an extremely learning
subject who had no problems
to admit that something
what he wrote or said
two years ago was wrong.
That he had now a new insight
which has to be taken into account.
This, by the way, is also
a reason that why so many
of Marx works including
capital were not finished
because he was permanently learning.
He did not just fulfill a program
and sent the manuscript to the reader.
So just for "Capital"
I think I can say that it
was not finished in the 70s.
It had of course,
one of the reasons were that Marx was sick
in the 70s, that also in the
in the early 70s he was
politically very engaged,
very active, but also in the 1870s
he extended the plan for
"Capital" considerably.
And I would say he could
extended it even so much
that even when he lived 10 years more
and would have the best health,
he wouldn't be able to finish
this extremely ambitious project.
And also this, we have to
have in mind when we discuss
about "Capital" that we have
not one finished project
we have an evolving project.
We have to see how things are developing.
I will come back to this point in short.
Now I just want to give you
a very, very rough idea.
What were the struggles behind "Capital".
Marx of course dealt with the
existing political economy,
this political economy was one
of the main justifying
sciences for capitalism.
So it was not just a scientific debate.
It was a debate about the science
which has central
importance for capitalism.
And in this times
he, in "Capital", he made
the famous distinction
between classical political
economy on the one hand
which he accepted as a scientific approach
a bourgeois approach but
nevertheless a scientific approach
and vulgar economics, which
was not really scientific.
It remained on the surface
and in the course of
time, more and more this,
what he called vulgar
economics became more
and more apologetic.
It was clear for the writers
we have to defend capitalism
and we have to present capitalism in a way
that it is the best world ever.
But there is a third branch
not so Marx made it not so prominent
but you can can see it in some footnotes
in some remarks,
this was especially the
German economists of his time.
He considered German economists
of his time, even worse
than the vulgar economists.
Germany developed rather
late, economically.
It was behind England and
France, in the first half
of the 19th century.
So there was not really an empirical basis
for doing political economy.
And the German economists took some,
some fragments from Adam Smith,
Ricardo say which they
not even really understood
They mixed it up
with some German historical consideration.
And the result for Marx was
not at all a serious project.
Another frontline for Marx
were competing socialist
thinkers, for example
Proudhon who he mentioned
several times in "Capital".
They also made use of
classical political economy
in a way which Marx criticized very much.
So Marx had to fight
against very different
camps in his "Capital".
I will mention later what this means
for certain points.
But now I have to
mention in this paragraph
just one point regarding the
publication of "Capital".
I said the German
economists were even worse
then the vulgar economists
in England and France,
but in which language
and where "Capital" was
published in Germany
Marx in his letters said,
"Oh, nobody really discusses 'Capital'".
And he talked about a
conspiracy of silence.
My idea is there was
not so much a conspiracy
of silence against the book.
There was the German
economists in the majority.
They're really unable
to understand the book
they were before unable
to understand really
classical political economy.
And so they didn't understand the critique
of classical political economy.
They also thought that it is
not necessary to criticize
because the critic of the Germans
was, "Oh, David Ricardo is too abstract.
We cannot use such an abstract theory."
And this was reason enough to say,
"Oh, we must not occupy it".
but now you can say,
okay, Marx book was not
it didn't aim to the
academic debate in Germany.
It was a book with socialist aims.
It was written to support
the proletarian relation
the proletarian revolution.
A book for workers.
But could the workers
really make use of "Capital"
in this time, they were first
the selling price of the book.
The first edition had a price which was
around the weekly income
of a skilled worker.
So far the for the most
workers in Germany,
the book was not affordable.
In the first edition, also Marx didn't.
And also in, in later editions
he didn't translate the
quotes from foreign languages.
You could find five different languages
in "Capital", ancient Greek, Latin,
English, French, and Italian.
He used a lot of terms
from ancient mythology,
philosophy, world literature, and so on.
So it was really a book
for that educated, very
well educated reader.
And these were in these
times, mainly the bourgeoisie.
So it is not surprising
that his book was not really a success
in the first years after it was published.
And when finally, 20 years
after the first edition, an
English translation appeared
then Marx opponent classical
political economy already had vanished.
Marginalists were ruling.
So the book looked
like a relic of an old
time, which has no meaning
for the present times.
So regarded under the
marketing aspects "Capital"
during the first 20 years
was really a disaster.
And also of course, this then
influenced the reception.
Now I want to come
to my next point before I then really come
to the critical issues of value theory.
I imagined that we mean
that we need a critical
reading of Marx texts.
There is not only in
reading Marx, but also
in reading a lot of other
so-called classical authors
a tendency to look for a last
version where the author said
what he really want to say.
In most cases, the search
for such an illusionary,
for such a last version
is really illusionary.
In Germany, this insight is rather old
and it led to the
so-called critical editions
not only to edit the last,
the so-called last version
of a book, but to publish
all the versions of the book
to publish also all the
changes in a single text.
In Germany, we have fortunately
the Marx-Engels-Gesamtausgabe
which it is not finished
but which gives such a critical
edition, which then need
which then makes possible
such a critical reading.
What this critical reading had, the impact
of this critical reading
even for volume one, I
to illustrate this, I
just give you one example.
You can hear very often the opinion
that the French translation
of volume one is the last version
because chronologically it appeared
after the first two German editions.
And it was really the last edition
on which Marx was working.
He checked the translation
and changed a lot of points
and even Marx wrote, yes,
"When you can read German, nevertheless,"
to the French readers he
said, "Even when you can read
German, you should read
this French edition.
It has a scientific value of its own".
But this is not the full truths.
The French edition brings
a lot of new insights,
new material, for example, in
the section on accumulation
but in the section on
value, it's a disaster.
And this also was confirmed by Marx
when Danielson the translator
for the Russian edition
asked what is best to do.
Marx told him use the second
German edition compare with
the French edition, but not
for the first chapters,
here you have to take
only the German edition.
What happened with these first chapters
in the French translation was simply
that Marx was not at all satisfied
with the translation of
the French translator
but he had not the time to
find better translations.
So in many cases, he
just erased sentences,
half sentences, half paragraphs.
When my commentary to the first
few chapters was translated
in France, there was a big problem
that in this standard translation
a lot of sentences I
commented they didn't exist
in this book.
In newer translations
they added the sentences
as an appendix, but
as you can imagine, most readers
didn't read the appendix.
So the translation
or this so-called last
version was really a problem
for understanding "Capital".
So now this was a long introduction
but I think it a necessary introduction.
I come to some critical
points of Marx value theory.
Many Marxists, as many Marx
critics have a very simple view
on value theory.
When you ask them, what's
tells you value theory
they say, "Okay, labor creates value.
The magnitude of labor spent
in production gives us
the magnitude of value."
So it looks
like that production
already determines value
and its magnitude and
money is just an expression
of value which exists also
without regarding money.
All these propositions I just quoted
in a briefly way are
very, very problematic.
And this, I want to show
now in this third part
about the critical points
of Marx value theory.
First, we have to be clear about Marx
way of presenting things.
For example, when you read
the first two chapters
of "Capital" many readers are puzzled
in chapter one in value form analysis
you find money in chapter two
you again can find money.
What's the difference?
And many say, okay, even you
can read this in commentaries,
"The presentation in chapter two
is a more concrete presentation."
This is nonsense.
There is a very clear
division between chapter one
and chapter two, chapter one
presents the form determination
and chapter two presents human action
ruled by this form determination
probably most of you
remember this famous sentence
from the preface that persons that
Marx criticizes the actions of capitalists
and land owners, but he is
not dealing with the character
of these persons because
they don't play a role
as persons but as personifications
of economic categories.
Probably, you know, the sentence
you all know the sentence.
Maybe you quoted it.
You used it, but this sentence implies
a very ambitious program.
When I really want to present persons
as personifications of economic categories
I must present first, the
economic categories independently
from the persons.
This already is a scientific
program in total contrast
to the program of
classical political economy
as well, neo-classical political
economy, because both start
with the individual and
the needs, the desire
or the possibilities of the individual,
and only from the action of the individual
they derive economic institutions.
Marx goes the opposite way in chapter one.
His object is the exchange
relation of commodities.
In chapter two, his object
is the exchange process
of commodity owners, and they do this
following their free
will, but this free will
when they want to avoid
economic bankruptcy has to
follow the form determinations
analyzed in chapter one.
So, and this pattern also exists later
in chapter four Marx analyzes
"Capital" and only this
in a very short remark
he comes to the capitalist
who makes the objective aim
of capital to his or her subjective aim.
So this we have to have
in mind, do we speak
about form determinations
or do we speak about action?
It makes a big difference for Marx.
- Michael.
Can I ask you a question?
- Of course.
- At this point
I would like to know your opinion
on this choice of Marx
to do science in this way
to start with the categories
to imagine that persons
are personifications
of categories, where does that come from?
Or let me ask you this.
What in "Capital" makes it right
that you make this scientific choice?
- Okay.
These are two different
question where it comes from
is more or less biographically
a question where which,
where the learning processes
of Marx to do this because in the 1840s
it was not so clear this difference.
I think it started in early 1850s
in his notebooks where he
was working day after day
in the British museum in London.
To justify this program
we just have to see if the analysis works.
When we look, for example, in chapter two
in "Capital" already Marx tries to explain
on a rather general abstract level
what commodity owners have to do.
And there we can check is
this analysis convincing
that what they have to do is exactly
the form determination
analyzed in chapter one.
We have to discuss this.
And here I, this is just a
in brackets set, the first
edition, the value form analysis
of the first edition in this
respect is much more precise
than in the second edition
the first edition starts
with a different force
value form not already
with the money form, but
with a kind of crazy value form where
every commodity is the general equivalent.
But exactly this appears
in chapter two, where Marx,
I think very clearly states
what do the commodity owners desire?
Every commodity owner has the desire
that his or her commodity
is the general equivalent.
So the crazy force value form
of the first edition is exactly the desire
of the commodity owners,
which is not realistic.
And therefore they have to come to money.
So the program
I think is convincing of
Marx, but this doesn't mean
that the way Marx presented
this program is correct
or convincing in every detail,
there is some work to do.
So now I want to come
to the next critical point,
double character of labor.
Everybody knows this really
in an audience I would
ask, "Where is my mistake
when I say a double character of labor?"
Marx didn't speak of
double character of labor.
His book about the double character
of labor represented in commodities.
Double character is not
a not historical feature
of any labor.
It is a feature of labor
represented in commodities.
So it is a historical
feature only existing
in a commodity producing society.
Here again, we have a decisive critique
against Adam Smith and
the classical school
because they not only don't do this
differentiation double character
abstract and concrete labor,
they confuse concrete labor,
what we have in every society
with abstract labor, what
belongs to commodity production.
And by this confusion, they
make commodity production
to something which has to exist always.
And the laws
of commodity production of
capitalist commodity production
for Adam Smith are the
loss of the economy.
So, this is a very critical
distinction critic against
the classical school, but
also it is very important
for the later use in "Capital"
when you come to the difference
for example, between
constant and variable capital
again, plays this double
character, a decisive role.
But what I want to stress here
in connecting this value theory is
that how did we find abstract labor?
We needed the exchange process,
in the exchange process
there is an abstraction from use value.
When we abstract
from every use value, then
automatically the labor changes.
It is not any more, a concrete labor.
It is a kind of abstract labor.
It is not an abstraction done consciously
by someone, it is a practical
abstraction existing
in everyday practice.
But this means that abstract
labor is connected to exchange.
When we only consider production
we cannot talk about abstract labor
and not talk about value.
The same, by the way, is true regarding
the magnitude of value.
You all know the famous definition
from the first five, six
pages of the first chapter
that not the individually spent
labor time forms the magnitude
of value, but only socially
necessary labor time.
But what is socially necessary labor time?
It is labor time
which in average, at a
certain situation is necessary
but which labor enters this average
not all the labor spent in production
but only that labor whose
products enter the market.
When you have a perfect factory
which will not deliver
products to the market
the labor conditions of this
factory will not influence
socially necessary labor time.
So also about the magnitude
of value, we can only speak
regarding not only production
but production and exchange.
The third of these critical
points, value form.
I already mentioned it shortly, value form
in the first chapter from
simple value form to money form.
Very often, it is misunderstood
as a kind of abbreviated
historical development of money.
But when you read cautiously already
the introductionary part of
this sub chapter on value form
then you can see Marx is
not speaking about money.
He is speaking
about the money form, the
necessity of the money form.
The necessity of a form
is not a historical event.
And the necessity
of a form relates to
the system of categories
with which I describe
an existing totality.
Is it necessary to have this form
in order to describe,
to analyze this totality
or is it not?
The background of this
seemingly abstract reasoning
is very political.
When Marx started with
"Grundrisse", he was occupied
with a pupil of Proudhon, a
French author named D'Adamo
and there he discussed, D'Adamo
discussed Proudhon thesis,
what is socialism, and Marx
went into this discussion.
Proudhon's basic idea
was to introduce a kind
of commodity production without money.
And this gave reason to Marx
to think about the connection
between commodity and money.
Is it only a superficial
connection so that you can get rid
of money, or is it much deeper?
His first result, Marx
first result presented
in 1859 in a contribution to the critique
of political economy
was a kind of confusion.
He confounded analysis of value form
with analysis of the exchange process.
He himself discovered these shortcomings
in early sixties when he works
on theories of surplus value
and he occupied with Samuel Bailey,
and English economists
in early 19th century.
Bailey criticized Ricardian
theories of value.
Bailey said, "Value always is
only a relational category,"
in the sense of relative value.
And the Ricardians try to
transform a relational thing
in an absolute thing,
which is not existing.
And now Marx wanted on the
one hand to criticize Bailey.
But on the other hand, he also saw
that the Ricardians were
unable to criticize Bailey.
So this showed that there
was a massive mistake,
massive shortcoming in the
classical Ricardian theory.
And by this
he learned that also he
himself did a certain confusion
in the book of 59.
And this gave then reason for
the first full presentation
of value form analyzes in the
first edition of "Capital".
But because this first presentation
of value form analysis was so
difficult to read, Marx was criticized
by Engels and by his
friend, Louis Cooperman.
And it was said, nobody will understand.
Marx then produced a much simpler version
as an appendix to the first edition.
And what we now read
in the standard editions of
"Capital" is much more close
to the popularized appendix
than to the strict
presentation of first edition.
So I just mentioned this
that you see you have on the
one hand, a certain progress
in March Marx analysis
but sometimes you have also a kind
of regress of introducing
some popularization
which makes the things less clear.
And also this is an argument in value form
analysis very clearly
there is not one best
version of value analysis,
of value form analysis.
When you really want to work
on it, you need all
the different versions.
Now, my next point is fateishism.
Also here, we have an
evolution in Marx thinking
it evolved rather lately.
I don't give you the
the history of this because
I always look to the clock
and the time is running, in first edition
finally, the, it is
treated more extensively
but only in the second
edition fateish character
of the commodity is put
together to one section.
It is a rather long section,
but we can say nearly
until the second half of 20th
century, it was mainly ignored
in discussion from Marxists
as well from Marx critics.
The interest started mainly
in the second half of 20th century
but then very often
fateishism was read as a kind
of wrong consciousness, there
is a deceiving of people.
They believe that value
is an objective property
of things, but it is not.
But this is really a misunderstanding
of the theory of fateishism.
Marx stresses that fateishism
is a reality commodities
have this feature.
And why do they have this?
Not as a result of a belief.
No, they have this feature
because of a certain practice
because of the way the
producers relate to each others.
They relate not directly to each other.
They relate mediated
through their products.
And in so far, this Marx
stresses in "Capital",
in the section, on fateishism,
the social properties
of the producers and their
labor become social properties
of their products.
This is a necessity in
commodity production.
The decisive, very short,
but decisive explanation in "Capital"
in penguin edition, you can
find in the pages 165, 66
I just want to read one sentence.
Now I quote, "The labor of the private
individual manifests itself as
an element of the total labor
of society, only through
the relations, which the act
of exchange established
between the products
and through the mediation
between the producers.
To the producers, therefore,
the social relations
between their private labors appear
as what they are."
This, "As what they
are," is very important.
It says it is not wrong consciousness.
"They appear as what they are.
They do not appear
as direct social relations
between persons in their work
but rather as material
relations between persons
and social relations between things."
So I quoted this also
before it becomes clear
that value theory for Marx
is not just the theory
which explains us the exchange relations
of different commodities,
value theory in Marx is a social theory.
It should explain how
in this rather perverse
and I mean this literally,
in this perverse economy
economy is possible, why it's perverse?
You have, on the one hand
as social division of labor
each producer is dependent
on a lot of other producers.
There is a very strict social connection
but the production is organized as
if all producers were
Robinson's on a remote Ireland.
They behave, the producers
behave atomistic.
They do their decisions independently
from all the other producers
and how this craziness
that you have a connection, a
necessary material connection
by all with the division of labor.
And nevertheless you'll behave
as if the others wouldn't exist.
How this can work this special functioning
of an economy should value theory explain
in so far, it is a social theory.
And in this social theory
exchange plays a crucial role.
There are a lot of opinions
who present Marx value theory
determined by production already.
These production oriented approaches
miss the special character of value theory
as a social theory, they also
miss the special character
of a capitalist economy.
So the question depends value
only on production, or depends
on production and exchange is not
a small theoretical question where
you can write your PhD thesis about, but
without much political impact.
It, I think it is a very decisive question
how to analyze, how to
understand capitalism.
And here at this point
I come to the next, very
related of the critical issues.
It is money.
When production already determines value
then money is just the
expression of something
what already exists before.
Not very important.
In Marx, it's rather different.
In chapter three of "Capital"
where Marx discusses the
functions of money he discussed
as the first function measure of value.
Marx there mentions
that abstract labor is the
inner measure of value.
Already in the first pages of "Capital"
Marx stressed that value
is across a crystal of abstract labor
but now Marx introduces
money as measure of value.
And not just as another
additional measure.
No, he introduces money as the
only real measure of value.
Why?
Why he's doing this?
Because abstract labor,
as I try to explain before,
you cannot find trust in the production
when you measure labor with a clock
you always measure the concrete
individual labor of a certain worker.
Abstract labor you can only find
in exchange, but in exchange
the commodities are
exchanged against money.
At least when we have it to do with
an developed exchange in
capitalist production.
So money is the only
real measure of value.
Abstract labor is, and
a strong analytical tool
but you cannot use it for a real measure.
Money as a measure of value
has its own properties.
It can measure value correctly
and it can measure value
in a not correct way,
price and value can differ and even more,
money can give a price to something
which has no value.
Marx stress this in chapter three.
So when we now take these
critical issues together
I think we can really speak
of monetary value theory in Marx.
It is not a production
oriented value theory.
It is a monetary value theory
where we however, have
also to regard that money
in this theory is not just a simple thing
as it is very often regarded.
I just remind you the
steps of analysis of money
at the beginning of "Capital"
in chapter one necessity
of the money form.
Chapter two, commodity owners act
as character masks of
personifications and forced to sought
out real money, a commodity as real money.
And chapter three,
the money functions, not
as an arbitrary enumeration
but derived from commodity circulation.
And this is not the last step
in the theory of money.
In volume three regarding credit
we will find credit money and
fictitious capital and so on.
So money itself is a complicated
thing which plays a role
or which is developed for
all volumes of capital.
So I said, taking all
these critical issues
I try to present you briefly together
we can say Marx value
theory is a monetary theory
which needs production
and exchange production
and circulation to explain something.
And this story of value theory continues.
It's not at the end, in the third chapter
it continues with capital,
not the book "Capital"
the thing and the category capital.
Also here, we can say Marx presents
a monetary capital theory.
Already in chapter four,
when Marx analyzes the
circulation figure MCM dash
money commodity more money.
He starts the discussing
the formed determination
of capital with money, and he stresses
that capital needs money as
an independent expression
of capital only in the using capital
you can also do all the
accountings later with profit rate
as a measure
for valorization and so on.
Production and exploitation come
into the game already in a chapter five
and six, they shall
explain why valorization
which we found in the formed
analysis, is possible.
It rests on exploitation,
but you cannot reduce
capital just on exploitation.
Exploitation you have
in every class society
in a society or in an
economy based on slave work
or in a society like in
medieval times on unfree work
and so on everywhere
you have exploitation.
But to understand the specific
capitalists structure of
exploitation, you need money
and Marx himself stresses this
in at the end of the fifth chapter.
Let me just read one short quote
which you can find in penguin
edition on the page 268
where first Marx describe
the contradiction in
attempts to explain capital.
So Marx concluded now the quote,
"Capital cannot therefore
arise from circulation
and it is equally impossible for
it to arise apart from circulation.
It must have its origin
both in circulation and
not in circulation."
So also capital is not
something which you can reduce
to production like value.
You need production and circulation.
And now when you look on the
structure of the three volumes
of "Capital", volume one
focuses on production
after the first five chapters,
and many people think,
"Oh, this is the core of
Marx analysis of capitalism."
No, the whole is the core.
You need the second volume
on circulation, and you
need the third volume
of the process as a whole, where profit
and interest is introduced
such important categories.
And from these two further volumes
the second and the third volume
you also can learn that
you cannot make a division
which is very popular between a
so-called real capital and a speculative
financial area as if this
were two different worlds.
No, the same way as you cannot have
a pure value sphere apart
from any money relations
you can have a pure capitalist real
production sphere apart
from any speculation,
money market, credit, interest
fearing capital and so on.
This is very important for
understanding contemporary capitalism.
And of course it is very important
when we want to fight against capitalism.
When we want to overcome capitalism
we must really understand
capitalism as a whole.
However, my time is at the end
I had to speak here about value theory.
So understanding capitalism as a
whole is another story I will
finish here at this point.
And thank you very much
for your patience and for your attention.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you Michael.
This is the place where there
would be thunderous applause.
I like to mark the place, what
we're missing in this world.
So imagine it's there.
I should, you know
they make us into these TV,
these unwilling TV celebrities.
We should at least have an applause track
I'm gonna ask for that next
time, maybe not a laugh track.
And so thank you very much.
I want to ask people to put questions
in the chat, which they're already doing.
I wanna start out with one question to you
if you don't mind, it's going
back to the relationship
between money and socially
necessary, average labor time.
If you don't mind.
I just want to hear a little
bit more about this from you.
I've read a lot
about it from you, but I think
it's good for people to hear.
I'm thinking of the first
page of chapter three
where he says at the end,
I'm gonna read the penguin
which we are working with my colleague
Paul Reitter to update
in a new translation
but they say in the penguin,
"Money as a measure of value
as the necessary form of
appearance of the measure of value
which is imminent of the
commodities, namely labor time."
So I can understand you saying
that, bringing money
back into the equation,
let's say, and changing the
revolutionary possibilities
of the book by doing that.
- Okay, the last remark is a
little bit too pathetic to say,
"Oh, now I changed everything".
- Well you don't change everything.
But you add, I mean, it isn't that well
that's a long discussion
anyway, that's my hope
But still he has to call
it a form of appearance.
So I wanna know if you could
say more than what role does the
immanent form have socially
necessary labor time
in the value form.
Money measures it practically.
I know that I'm gonna
measure value in money.
We know this, what you don't
know, what's being shown
by Marx is that you're
actually measuring it in
in socially necessary labor time
which is a huge innovation,
it seems to me, over the
classical political economists
and over the, let's say a kind
of empirical view of
the economy, which says
that money is the money
is the root of everything.
It's really about money.
Here it's about how people's efforts,
social efforts to make something
are valued when they're put together
with other social efforts to make things
in the exchange realm.
So I agree completely that it's
between production and
exchange, that value arises
but what role does this
imminent form play?
And why should the form
of appearance be given
such pride of place?
- This eminent form, this eminent measure
of value plays the crucial
role in understanding value.
Value is a certain kind of
objectivity, now we came
to the translation problems in German.
I would say, (speaks in foreign language).
A certain time of, (speaks
in foreign language),
thing like ness.
When I allow to construct an English word
a certain kind of objectivity
which on the one hand has features
of physical objectivity of
analog to in an analog way
to physical objectivity,
but it is not physical.
And this special kind of objectivity
I think is one of the
main discoveries of Marx.
When you look to the
history of political economy
there is a certain dispute
is economy a science,
a natural science
with physical quantities?
Or is it a kind of psychology
because it deals with consumer
preferences and so on.
And the discussions are
sometimes very stupid
when you read this.
Marx, I think exactly in his
value theory can show value is
neither the one nor the
other, neither it has to do
with physical quantities.
It is not like a natural science
but it is also not a kind of psychology.
And to understand this special objectivity
you need the term abstract labor
the difference concrete
and abstract labor.
So it is a necessary
step in the appropriation
of our object of research
in the introduction
of 1857 Marx made this
nice remark relating
to Hagle that we must appropriate
in our thoughts, the objective thing
we do research and this we
can do only with categories.
And so abstract labor is one
of the decisive categories
for this appropriation
but it is not at all a
category you can measure.
You can, you can say 10
hours abstract labor.
This term makes absolutely no sense.
Here you need money.
And when you talk
about, or Marx talks about a shyness form,
a form of appearance, we also
have to be very cautious.
Many people know this term
maybe coming from a Galilean philosophy
there is an essence, and
there is a form of appearance.
And many people think, ah
essence is the essence.
The important part
and form of appearance is
something hanging around
not so important, but
this is totally wrong
already with Hagle
form of appearance is
absolutely necessary.
And in Hagle not to
put apart from essence and
now read "Capital" volume one.
Where do you find the term essence?
Not in the first few
chapters, you have form
of appearance, but without essence.
So this means also form
of appearance is something
different from what Hagle means.
And also what many contemporary
Marxists understand this form
of appearance, but for our
discussion, it is important.
It is not any subordinated.
So I hope I could give some
ideas to your question.
- Many, many ideas.
I thank you for it.
We have a lot of questions in the chat.
So what I'm going to do,
let's see how many do
we have, maybe about 10.
I think we'll just do
it the way we usually do
which is we'll start with the first one.
- Yeah, hi thanks Michael,
for this interesting talk
I just had a quick
question about your claim
that Marx begins the "Capital" volume one
with form determination
instead of human action.
But I'm very interested
myself in those opening pages
and the way that Marx
says that a use value
to a consumer is a necessary
condition for a commodity.
Otherwise, an object won't be exchanged
and it can't have exchange value at all.
And so it can't even be a commodity.
So with that in mind,
can't we say that commodities always begin
with human action and
therefore Marx account
of commodities, even though
he's obviously concerned
with form determination also
begins with human action?
- Okay, why don't we take one more?
Does that sound right?
Thank you Tristan.
Let's open up Michael Pulsford.
Michael, you'll be next.
Or if we don't get to Michael
or if Michael has left
I can read the question.
That's fine.
- Not think that they are still on.
- Well let's ask the question anyway,
for the sake of fairness.
I'll go ahead and do it.
This is from Michael.
"Did Marx say anything
about marginal theories
of value and what do you think
he might've said about value
if he was writing a critique
of political economy, a few decades later
and marginal theories
of value were dominant?"
This is a great question.
I would have asked it myself.
So Michael, if you're
listening, thank you.
Okay Michael, I think you're on.
- Okay, shall I answer?
Okay.
Interesting questions
maybe we will have a long evening.
I will start with the
second question of Tristan.
You mentioned that Marx
in the first sub section
of the first chapter already stressed
every commodity needs use value
otherwise it cannot be a commodity.
And if this not means that he
also starts with human action
then I understood correctly.
I think Marx mentioned,
it is totally correct
what you said about Marx,
he mentioned this as a kind
of general prerequisite.
It must have use value and it must
have use value for others.
Not only for me then
it's also not a commodity
but this general prerequisite doesn't
constitute a certain approach
on which he's building.
He also could say
when we have commodity
production and exchange
it is done by humans.
Humans have to breathe, without breathing
there is no commodity
production, but does this mean
that Marx would have
presented a biologist approach
when just stating people
always have to breathe
it would only give a very,
very general prerequisite.
And in such way, I would
interpret the, what you mentioned.
Marx says okay, it must have use value,
but now let's analyze the economic forms.
And the action comes then
in the second chapter
which already starts
with this nice sentence
the commodities cannot
go alone to the market.
Therefore we have to
look for their owners.
So also here Marx makes clear
now we change perspective.
Now first we really come to
the persons and the actions.
The third question about marginal theory
is this is really an interesting point.
There were some very rough predecessors
in British economy who
also tried not make use
of marginal theory, but of utility theory
Marx knew them and counted
them as vulgar economics.
But I found no hint that he ever saw
the book of Jevons.
The book of Jevons was published
in London in the year 1871 or 72.
A time by Marx was in London
where he followed economic discussions
neither in a letter, neither in a draft,
in a notebook, nowhere
this book or another book
of marginalist literature is mentioned.
So far, and I would expect to
find at least a short remark
what nonsense nowadays
produced or something,
but no, nothing.
Another book of Jevons.
He knew about the coal production
the coal industry, a book,
which appeared earlier.
So he also knew the
name, but not this book.
And in so far
I think he missed the rise
of this marginalist theory.
He was in 70, 71, he was very occupied
with the civil war in France
to write civil war in France
with the Paris comun.
Then he was sick.
Then he was trying to finish
volume two of "Capital".
And this marginalism, he
missed this marginalism.
And when he couldn't miss
it, because it was so broad
in the 80s, he was dead.
So he didn't see it.
And you asked also what would be his
estimation, difficult question.
I would say, I would suppose his
answer to it would have two
paths, stressing utility.
He would criticize very heavily.
To introduce mathematical formalism
in, especially the differential calculus
he would appreciate.
He himself did intensive
study of differential calculus
since mid of the 60s
there are mathematical
notebooks, only one is published
until now, but there are
more mathematical notebooks
which will be published in mega.
And from this, you'll see
that he really was engaged
occupying knowledge, not
he was not a researcher
a mathematical researcher, but
he was a person who tried to
learn all this calculus.
So now the first question,
which has several parts
and which not, I think not all parts
are so narrow to my talk.
One part is you mentioned pessimists
Adornian outlook, or Adornian theories.
And I think I also
mentioned this in Brighton.
Some people, some pupils
of Adorno understand
fateishism as a closed system
you cannot, you cannot
escape from fateishism.
It is everywhere.
If this would be true
then the question is, how
can we talk about fateishism?
When we are such imprisoned by fateishism
how can we analyze it?
So this totally closed world
by fateishism cannot exist.
Otherwise we couldn't talk about
and I would say fateishism is an
always present background
for workers, for capitalists,
for academics non academics,
and we cannot escape this background
but how we react to this background
what this background is doing with us
has to do with our practice,
our practical life as well
with our knowledge with
our intellectual life
what we do learn.
And here I would say
at least with these
extreme Adornian pupils
I have big differences.
You also mentioned pessimistic outlooks.
This is true in Adorno.
And in, especially I think even
more in Horkheimer you
can find such a pessimism.
Also this, I wouldn't
share, Adorno and Horkheimer
they had the experience of fascism.
They had the experience
of nearly break down
of human society by fascism
and by the second world war.
And they had reason to be pessimistic
but in analytical terms
I think there is not such a good reason.
And when Adorno and
Horkheimer saw the hints
that they, they have not to be so
pessimistic when the
students movement emerged
they had big problems with
the student movements.
I think also because they were
in a pessimistic way prejudiced.
Nowadays, I think we also have reason
to some pessimism because a
totally different situation.
Capitalism is destroying so much
the planet that perhaps the capitalism
will have destroyed the planet
and our foundations
of living before we can
succeed to destroy capitalism.
It is a competition in time.
And I must say
I'm not sure if we will
win this competition.
So this could be a pessimist, also a kind
of pessimism, but this
could be totally different
from Adornian or Horkheimer pessimism
but also in this case,
I still have some hope.
- Okay, thank you.
We're going to do a few more questions.
We'll start with my
colleague, Paul Reitter, Paul?
- Michael, thank you so much
for your talk and for being here.
I can't remember
whether or not Paul
said this, but you know
Michael is in Berlin right now.
So it's 1:30 in the morning
and you know, the energy and lucidity
at this advanced hour
really are quite stunning.
So I admire that and much
else about this presentation.
I want to ask a question
that I've asked before.
And so I forgive people in the
audience who are maybe tired
of this question by now, but
this time is a little different
because, whereas I don't
think the question has gotten
that much traction with
previous presenters,
you actually have spoken
to this issue a bit and seem
interested in taking it up.
And the issue is what it is
on the level of, on the level of rhetoric.
How is it
that this text lends itself
to misreadings and you talked
about the popularizing
formulations in the section
on value that you think
are a bit misleading.
And I would be really interested to hear
some examples of that.
- Of the misreadings?
- Or of the popularizing formulations
in the 1872 edition that lend themselves
to misreadings misinterpretation.
- [Michael] Okay.
- Michael I'll read one
that from the chat, just to add
to your list, this is
from Anne Lee Summers.
She asked me to ask the question,
"Could professor Heinrich
comment on the usefulness
of studying book four of
"Capital" namely theories
of surplus value in the
context of a critical reading
of 'Capital' volumes, one, two, and three
you seem to emphasize those three
but not so much the
supposed or potential four.
Also, could you comment on
the accuracy or usefulness
of Alan Oakley's 1983
bibliographic analysis
of Marx's critical theory?"
So that's two questions
from Anne Lee Summers.
And shall we give you one more?
- Alan Oakley's what I,
I didn't understand that-
- 1983 bibliographic analysis
of Marx's critical theory.
I don't know that myself, but.
- Yeah
I know the name of Alan Oakley,
but this book, I don't know.
I have nothing to say.
- Okay.
Now-
- I will say later.
- Okay, shall we have one-
- Do another one.
- Okay, so Audrey, could
you open Allen Sbanotto?
- [Allen] Hi, can hear me?
- Yes, we hear you fine.
- [Allen] All right.
I hope this isn't too narrow or technical
but I just wanted to ask,
you had mentioned the value
of a commodity can differ from its price.
And that makes sense.
There's all kinds of
reasons why that can happen
but can the sum
of all values of commodities
be different from the sum of all prices?
- Okay, thank you.
You know, this is a beautiful opportunity
where you can ask both
questions about the end
of the world and incredibly
technical questions.
And professor Heinrich
handles them both with grace.
Do you want to start
with these or do you want to
ask, do you want some more?
- Maybe one more question.
- Great, so.
Okay, this is a little bit,
little bit off topic,
but let's do it anyway.
Could you Audrey open Jack Copely?
Jack, are you there?
Reminds me of all the hours.
I spent listening to
talk radio in my life.
They have someone who makes
sure the person is there.
I can read Jack's question if
he's not on the list anymore.
What do you think Audrey?
- Someone in the chat said
that his mic does not work.
- Okay so then I'll read the question.
Sorry.
He says, "Wonderful
talk, before capitalism
there existed in certain places and times
money, wage labor, market exchange,
private property, et cetera.
Can we say that abstract labor
and the law of value
existed in incipient form
on the margins of such
pre capitalist societies?"
Oh, he says his microphone doesn't work.
I'm so sorry.
I see it now.
Okay, Michael I'll let
you go for those four.
- Yeah, I will start
with the last question.
It is a very important question.
We are very used to say money,
commodities, even capital or
private property exists long,
long ago before capitalism.
This is not completely true.
We have to consider that all
this, property, money, capital
in pre capitalist societies is different.
You have the capitalist
property in nowadays.
What, what is common
to us is defined by the
exclusion of others.
When you want to define what is property,
private property, I can exclude
anybody else from the use.
This is my ground.
I don't allow you to use it.
Then it is my property.
This is a rather new constellation
in all pre capitalist societies
you had something you
can call private property
but with social obligations, the exclusion
of the others was not the
common feature of property.
Also with money.
When you see some coins,
you think, oh, that's money.
But also this is not true.
You have, on the one hand
the use of this coin followed
in parts, different rules
according to the situation,
it is money, nowadays is abstract wealth.
But the so-called money
in pre capitalist times
was something bound
in certain social relations.
Even what we nowadays call
functions of money were
in some societies distributed
to different bearers
a mean of circulation, means
of circulation was different
from measure of value or
from a storage of value.
So you cannot just say, "Oh,
this exists all the time".
And in so far
I would also say there was not
a double character of labor
like the analysis with
capitalist commodity.
And of course not in the
same way, abstract labor.
And this point is even discussed
very briefly in "Capital"
in the first chapter
when Marx made this excursus on Aristotle.
Why Aristotle couldn't
come to value theory.
He was restricted by the
structures of his society.
And one could add this,
he was not that something
existed and he couldn't see, no,
it didn't exist in the
way it exists nowadays.
And this is also important when we, now,
especially with the Marxist approach
analyze pre capitalist societies
we must be extremely cautious
not just to project our categories
on the pre capitalist society.
Then our analysis will go very wrong.
So now the second.
Ah, no, no, no, no,
the third I can do it
really the opposite order.
The third question value
differs from price.
And you asked can also the sum
of value differ from the sum of prices.
I don't know how you mean this question.
There is the so-called
transformation problem.
It is between value
theory, as it is presented
in volume one in volume
three, we have a theory
of production prices
and Marx tries to show
that production prices
still ruled by values.
He even offers a way
of accounting, how we can
account starting with values,
the production prices and
the average rate of profit
but this accounting is
wrong, what he presents
and the ironic point is that he knew this.
He mentioned this
that this is wrong, but he
said it doesn't play a role
because he didn't want to go in details.
Later on, it came out,
it played a much bigger role
than Marx expected this.
I don't know
if you have this in mind,
when you have this in mind
I must say, now is the time to show,
to come to the transformation problem
then I first would have to
explain what this means.
I wrote about this in "Signs
of Value", for example.
So I must put the answer to the book.
When you just stay on the level
of volume one where I said,
yes, money expresses value
and it can express more or less value.
Then it is for sure that
there is no necessary equation
that the sum
of all prices is equal
to the sum of all values.
It can be more, it can be less.
So second question about book four.
Here, first, we have to
distinguish, you identify it.
Book four, with theories of surplus value.
This is wrong.
This is definitely wrong.
Book for of "Capital".
The history of theories was never written.
There is not even a draft,
theories of surplus value
as the name already
indicates is just the history
of one category of surplus value.
But book four should be the
history of economic theory
what is a different thing.
Furthermore, the history of theory
Marx wanted to write when
he had all his categories.
So presupposing the
three theoretical books
and the categories.
He wanted to write the
history of the theory.
When Marx wrote theories
of surplus value, he didn't
have all the categories.
It emerged in the big manuscript
written between 1861 to 63
where he was in the middle
of his research process.
And this research process continued also
after finishing theories of surplus value.
The research process continued
on the one hand regarding
the theoretical categories
but it also continued on the field
of the history of economic theories.
In the year,
at the end of the year, 1863
Marx produced a new notebook.
The so-called "Bi Haftar"
accompanying notebooks.
A to G, they were numbered
by letters from A to G,
in this "Bi Haftar", they
are not published until now.
They will come in in mega of course,
but in this "Bi Haftar",
he widened his view
on economic theory enormously.
So, "Theories of Surplus Value",
luck in several dimensions
something what would make them even
to a draft for book four,
it is only one category.
The system of categories
of the theory is not ready.
And the research in the history
of theory went on after
"Theories of Surplus Value".
So "Theories of Surplus Value" is not
the number four, that the book is missing,
that this fourth book is
missing is really, really a blow
because in "Capital" Marx always relates
in footnotes, in small
remarks to Smith's and Ricardo
but we have nowhere, a big
presentation about Smiths
and Ricardo and such an
representation would be necessary
especially when you have in mind
what I said at the beginning
that after "Capital" appeared,
the marginalists came
and they rewrote the history
with these new distinctions.
If Marx would have clearly
defined his relation
to the classics more than in
the footnotes of "Capital"
it would be much more easy
to say clearly the framework
what the marginalist offer for the history
of theory is absolutely
not fitting for Marx.
So that we miss book four
has not only a scientific relevance
it also has a political relevance dealing
with competing theories.
So, and now I,
yeah, Paul Reitter is left.
Misreadings popular versions,
in the secondary edition
you have mainly as value form analysis
a reworking of the appendix
of the first volume, which
was already popularized
which also, I must say
has one big progress,
the three peculiarities
of the equivalent form appear
for the first time in the appendix.
This is really a progress compared with
the version of the first
chapter, first edition,
but that the force value form
of the first edition is missed
or is replaced in the second edition.
This is a big problem I think.
This is a lack what we have
and there are also some historising
insertions that in value form analysis
Marx starts with historical examples.
They only shall illustrate value form
or the different value forms, but this
of course supports this
historical reading of value form.
In the first edition,
you didn't have this,
then you have popularized remarks
also in other parts of the book
but they came not so much
from the second edition.
They come from the fourth edition,
the fourth edition of volume one.
Not prepared by Marx, but by Engels.
And what did Engels do in this edition?
He took the second edition,
the second German edition
and looked what are the
differences in the French edition
and also he had a small list
of Marx of changes he wants to do
for a third German edition or
for an English translation.
And Engels try to combine this.
Sometimes he did this very successfully.
Sometimes he did this not so successfully.
And the strictness in which Marx dealt
with the category was
a little bit blurred.
In one case, there is even
a translation mistake.
Engels had to translate
from the French edition
to the German when he
wanted to insert something
because there was not a German original
of the French edition.
And there is one small mistake.
Okay, the sense delivers nonsense
in the section on accumulation.
And it seems that nobody realized
that literally speaking
the the sense is nonsense
but these were very small points.
The more decisive point is
the overwhelming presence
of book one
of the production process
which structured the
perception of "Capital".
So I wouldn't say there
are so much misreadings
or so much phrases
in the second edition which
giving cause to misreadings.
I would more stress this special
reception putting production
process in the center.
This caused a big misreading.
- Okay, thank you.
It is about our closing time now.
There's been, there are some
more questions in the chat
and there's been some requests
that one question get aired.
And so I'm gonna air that question
as the last question with
apologies to everyone else.
That is a question from Lucas Guesser
and I'm just gonna read
it for the sake of time.
"There's been a lot of debate recently
in Brazilian economics
about the so-called
modern monetary theory.
Do you think it is compatible
with Marx's analysis of capitalism?"
Make this the last question
with great apologies
to all the people with also
great questions in the chat.
Michael?
- Yeah, this is a good question
but I would say we have to put this
in a little bit in a broader range.
Modern monetary theory,
now the time is too short to say something
what it is for the people
who don't know the term
it comes from some rather radical pupils
of Keynes from Keynesian school.
And there is the broader question
Keynesian theory and Marx on
critical political economy.
Do they fit together or not?
And here, I think we have
this question is prior
and here we have to deal
with Keynes in a similar way.
We have to deal with Marx.
With Marx I stress
we cannot take everything for
granted what the different Marxist
traditions tell us about Marx.
We have to see which
categories really fit to Marx.
The same is true for Keynesian economics.
Keynes was very often reduced
to a deficit spending policy.
And in some respect
this modern monetary
theory is a radicalization
of this approach
that we don't have to fear
deficits that deficits are good
for the development of the economy.
Keynes has to offer a much
more elaborated analysis
but like Marx also
in manuscripts not published
during his lifetime.
During his lifetime was in the year 1931,
the treaties on money
where he was half with one
leg fixed in neoclassical theory
and only with one leg beyond.
And then in 1936,
the general theory where he
tried to formulate a difference,
a basic difference to
neo-classical mainstream
but general theory, the published version
was already a popularized,
moderated version
of manuscripts which
emerged between 31 and 36.
There he developed a theory,
a monetary theory of production.
And this monetary theory of
production, I think has points
you can connect it very easily with Marx.
So there is the possibility
to connect something
but not on a superficial sphere.
And with modern monetary theory
I would say they have some good
points criticizing the mainstream
but what they have to offer
as a theory until now
is not really a theory.
It is some ideas about money
and the state and the state
debt which is rather premature.
So it is good that this approach exists.
It inspired a lot the discussion
but I think it is not something you
can just easily integrate
in the Marxian framework.
But to repeat this,
the radical side of Keynes' writings,
which were not published
in his lifetime, the manuscript were found
after his widow died
in the 70s and only then
they were published.
These manuscripts are very interesting for
when you occupy this
critic of political economy
in my "Science of value",
which finally will appear next year
I make some remarks to these manuscripts.
For the moment I will stop at this point.
- Thank you very much.
Again, this is where the
applause track would be.
We will be waiting
for the English version
of "The Science of Value".
We appreciate very much your fortitude
and your willingness
to answer all questions
your movement from the
technical to the revolutionary
to the historical, and really
is, it's a singular thing.
So I appreciate it very much.
Thank you for coming.